hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're in round
12 of our coverage of the 2018
candidates tournament only have a few
rounds left and today's match is an epic
one many people have been looking
forward to this match for a couple days
now as we started to figure out who was
gonna be in contention our competitors
whites gonna be played by Carter yakin
blacks gonna be played by Cara wanna the
reason this is so important cardiac in
he won this tournament two years ago
went on to face Magnus Carlsen in the
2016 World Championship took him to tie
breakers it was a very very close match
karyakin did not start this tournament
very well had first four games had two
draws two losses did not look like he
was gonna be in contention but he's come
storming Norman back since then and he
has the opportunity if he wins this
he'll be tied for first who will be tied
with that's right his competitor he's
playing today Cara Juana they will be
half a point behind the next person in
the field Caruana on the other hand he
knows what's at stake he almost won this
tournament two years ago eventually
losing out to cardiac in and he is
currently looking to just get a draw and
he'll be a point ahead of the field if
he can somehow get a victory the black
pieces he'll be a point in half with two
games left and there hasn't been an
American represented in the world
championship in over 20 years so he
knows what's at stake and understands
that if there's anyone he cannot lose to
it is his opponent today because that
would mean he would be tied so gonna be
looking for a draw if not a victory for
Cara Juana cardiac and looking to get
himself tied for first so he get started
pawn to e4 pon e5 Knight f3 Knight f6 so
getting into the petra of defense and
then after Knight takes on e5 pawn d6
force ignite to come back this is the
main line if you haven't seen the video
there is one that I've created you can
watch it if you're not too familiar with
this particular opening but Knight to c3
Knight takes on c3 pawn recaptures and
then Knight to c6 simple develop move
this is one of the more draw lines that
black a kinko down in one just the pawn
to e4 opening but as well on the petrov
defense as well just trying to exchange
as much material not trying to get into
anything complicated and then at the end
of it just try to get a quick draw and
then move on from there
why continues his development with
Bishop to e3 Bishop e7 Queen to d2
preparing for queenside castle Bishop e6
and then that's exactly what we see and
the king is pretty safe especially on
the Queen side with the pawn on a c3
just another layer of protection for
white here Queen to d7 opening up the
door for black to castle on the Queen
side as well
pawn to e3 pawn here to h6 just stopping
the Knight to g5 also the Bishop to g5
as well Knight to a d4 Knight takes
bishop takes here on a d4 so black just
look into exchange mints hero both sides
do have the bishop pair fairly open
board state right now not clear exactly
if it'll stay that way but bishops
definitely do stronger in an open board
state bishop is now attacking the square
here on a g7 so we see black play rook
to g8 this does signal that if like is
going to castle it is going to be on the
Queen side of the board which usually
does better for someone who's trying to
go for a draw game few castle on
opposite sides of the board usually it's
gonna be an all-out attack from both
sides throwing everything they can at
their opponents whatever side has castle
Don so they don't have to worry about
pushing their pawns forward so for those
Fabiano fans this is definitely the
position you want to see Bishop here - e
- and then pawn to c5 and this is where
it gets kind of crazy from blacks point
of view you know he's not gonna castle
on the King side it's gonna be looking
to castle on the Queen side you really
are expecting something like Queen to c6
attacking the pawn here on g2 since the
bishop you always want to look at where
your opponent just moved and what he's
no longer defending okay Bishop here to
e2 no longer defending this pawn here on
g2 so let's get the Queen involved into
the game can castle on the Queen side
has not really pushed any pawns in front
of it I could have also tried just pawn
to a6 not really stopping too much but
you know do want to stop a Vince
the bishop coming to be five and said
Fabio has had to get a little bit more
aggressive and played pawn to c5 very
sound move yes but very very tricky as
far as the trickle-down consequences
that come with a move like this because
if he does castle on the Queen side
there's a lot of air in front of that
King but he's gonna have to worry about
for the rest of the game so the bishop
comes back to e3 pawn to d5 so continue
to push forward trying to control the
center of the board pawn to f4 and then
castle on the Queen side I would say
white definitely has a much safer King
black mal does have the sinner control
so it's gonna be a matter of you know
from here can black stay safe can white
just blow up this board stay in the
center and start to attack blacks King
white plays Bishop here to f3 starting
to attack this center pawn on d5 which
does not have any protection from upon a
pawns gone and the C pawn here has
already pushed forward so white
recognizing that all the material from
black is now gonna have to protect this
starts to maneuvers pieces to both
control the center as well just attack
that pawn now Bishop down here to g4
says let's trade off material if you
want to but we see something fairly
crazy at least in my opinion this Bishop
takes on d5 says yeah I know you're
putting down my bishop to the rook here
but I'm gonna go ahead and give you my
rook so we see Fabiano take that and
then after the rook takes then Queen
here to c7 was this bishop here being
protected by the Queen and the rook and
then pawns who c4 so cardiac and is okay
with giving up his rook in exchange for
a bishop upon and then now controlling
the center of the board so things got a
lot crazier than we were expecting when
we first saw the beginning of the game I
thought it might even be a very quick
match with a draw but cardiac and saying
no that's not what we're doing here I'm
gonna give up some material because I
think I have a strong attack going from
Caruana stay
point it's really just a matter of can
he trade down he has the material
advantage he's up one pond
you know rooks generally worth a minor
piece and two ponds he gave up a minor
piece in one pond so can he stay safe
trade down material and then realize his
true equity that he has in the material
advantage that's really what it comes
down to work here to e8 trying to
control the center file Queen to f2 just
doubling up the attack on at the square
here on a c5 pawn to b6 kind of move we
were expecting in this position pawn to
g4 Bishop here to f6 King over to b1
trying to get it to a safer square also
just wants to get it off of this first
rank right here doesn't want you
shenanigans from black if the rook were
to ever come down here to this first
rank rook down to d7
rook appeared to d3 pawn down to g5 and
this is kind of interesting as far as
how black wants to approach this
he knows the LightSquared Bishop here on
d5 is not moving this is a great out
pose for for white so don't think he has
to worry could have even played pawn to
g6 knowing that yeah I can have it on a
light square but that's not gonna be too
worrisome because this bishops not
moving as soon as he moves it down here
to g5 we can start to see some strong
attacks since the darks for a bishop is
just eyeing down that square right there
so first we see King here to a2 rook to
e7 Queen here to f3 so cardiac in just
starting to build up all of his pieces
maneuvering them so they're all
defending each other and if he wants to
start a big attack he definitely has
some opportunities to do that King here
to d8 this is one of those questionable
moves for me it's its sound if you were
to run it through an analyzer but just
as I observe this position in in the
game you never really want to be putting
your king on active files this D file is
extremely active once the bishop starts
coming off the board or just moves all
of a sudden this rook is now eyeing down
on this King you pretty much have to
keep pieces in front of that King so
it's
attack just something else that Cara
Juana is gonna have to worry about for
the rest the game if he wants to keep
that king very active here on a d8
Bishop coming back here to d2 King to a
c8 now Queen down here to f1 rook to d6
and then the pond takes here on g5 and
the reason that we see the rook to d6
instead of something like pawn takes on
g4
okay well the bishop could take that's
on down attacking the Queen here on a c7
maybe Bishop to e5 just trying to trade
down material but they're just gonna
lose this material here on h6 why it's
able to gobble up more material that's
exactly what black does not want even if
you were to get some of this material
back here at the end of the day we have
four pawns for black and then on the
other side we have five pawns but you
can see a lot of pressure that white is
starting to mount that's not what blacks
looking to do here plays rook instead to
d6 and then after the pawn takes Bishop
recaptures pawn takes and then all of a
sudden okay yes we have no more bishops
a4 black we still have this pretty
annoying outpost here on a d5 that's
controlling so much of the board and we
do have these two pawns over here that
blacks gonna have to deal with is they
start to push forward put a lot of
pressure on Cara Juana now the Queen
comes up to f5 check rook to d7 and then
the Queen takes here on a g5 and it
starts to even look like black was just
miscalculating some of how the variation
would go not sure if he saw that there
was a a check here but this does give a
passed pawn opportunity for cardiac can
start pushing on the h-file just another
thing black's gonna have to deal with
Queen comes down here to e5 just says
please let's just go ahead and trade
also is attacking the pawn down here on
h2 does not want to take it right away
if he were to take if you're like well
yeah it's clearly open you could take
this this gets extremely bad Queen comes
up here to g8 few ways that black can
respond
they're all pretty terrible you could
have king to c7 okay that's queen to a8
is really the dagger move preparing for
the Queen to a seven
depending on where his opponent goes he
always has Queen here to b7 as well
maybe rook down to e2 start an attack
Queen a7 check Queen down here b6 check
it doesn't really matter where black
goes it's all gonna be pretty bad if we
come back and say well yeah the King's
not gonna move okay what if we're here
to eat it you can probably see that's
gonna be bad just the Queen's gonna take
here King to c7 very similar thing Queen
over here to a8 that's gonna be bad if
the other rook moves real here to d8
that's gonna be bad as well because the
bishop here to e6 this is a great
deflection check move because yeah
you're gonna want to take this bishop
but if you do well things get extremely
bad cuz Queen takes here on d8 after
your king moves you're just gonna gobble
off the more material so at the end of
the day yes black would like to go ahead
and just take this pawn but that would
be a huge mistake so Queen comes down
here to e5 says let's exchange material
Queen comes to h6 getting out of harm's
way and also still defending this square
here on h2 even though it doesn't have
to worry about it too much
King to the 8th another one of those
moves where I just don't like putting my
king in the center of the board which so
much attacking prowess from my opponent
pawn to g5 so White's starting to push
his pawns Queen back here to d6 Queen to
HX rook to e8 so blacks playing pure
defense mode right now Queen down here
to h4 and then Queen over here to g6
just trying to stop this pawn from
pushing any further Queen to g4 from
white rook down here to e5 pawn to h4
just adding another layer of protection
to this pawn here on g5 always nice when
your pawns can help in the defense King
here to e7 very aggressive move from
Fabiano rook down to d2 pawn to b5 says
yeah I recognize him I'm in some
pressure I need to relieve some of that
pressure by trying to attack on the
Queen's
but white doesn't worry about that says
okay in this position I'm gonna play
Bishop takes here on f7 this opens up
this is a really great deflection the
bishops attacking this Queen here on a
g6 but both the rook and the Queen are
now attacking this rook here on d7 so
you can't really profitably take this
White's gonna get some material in this
exchange Queen to f5 now rook up here to
d7 King takes and now after the exchange
pawn up to g6 this is a great outpost
but it also just protects this pawn here
on g6 I can just hang out there's
nothing that black can do unless he
wants to give up his rook here but
there's just so much pawn advantage that
White has that would be a bad thing so
getting into the the in parts of the in
game White has a monumental advantage in
Cara Juana is just sitting there trying
to figure out how he let this happen
King here d7 pawn takes on b5 rook to h5
says yeah I'm not too worried about the
pawn over there on h5 rook takes on h4
this pawn is protected by the bishop so
it doesn't have to worry about playing
something like King to b3 he can just
continue to push forward with his other
pawns pawn to a4 rook here to a g4 says
yeah don't even care if you take my pawn
I can overwhelm you on the Queen side of
the board pawn to e5 pawn up here to a6
solidifying the pawn chain King to c7
and then after King 2b 3 we see Fabiano
resign and you could tell that he was
just not comfortable throughout the
entire match every single move it seemed
like it was multiple Menace that he was
looking at it it didn't take him long
even most players they have so much
preparation for like the first 15 20
moves everything is under 30 seconds cuz
they know exactly what they're doing
didn't take Fabiano long before he was
getting into multiple minutes per moves
and he was like that for the entire game
cardiac and it a fantastic job of
continuously pressing his opponent
always attacking and it really did seem
like as soon as that palm pushed forward
here to c5 why just had a relentless
attack
going in black was not able to stop that
so we're gonna have some exciting games
the next couple days we do have tomorrow
off and then they come back for round 13
and 14 so we will have coverage of both
of those rounds but both these players
that we looked at today are tied for
first couple players right behind them a
half a point behind so it is about a 4
player race right now with these two
individuals and my guess it'll be one of
them so hopefully you guys are enjoying
this tournament Benson Pentax the game
so far looking forward to see how this
thing ends but thanks for watching and
I'll see you guys in the next video